ladies it is okay if you do not love keeping house
let me explain I never post in the morning
so I was gonna just do a little live update
just made my mushroom coffee
it's to die for I put butter and raw milk in it thank me later
anyway I don't think a woman has to love keeping her
my husband and I have gotten an argument about this before
I am one of those that likes to clean it one or two times
head to toe and then yes
you have to try to maintain it
but the things that I don't love is like
the two things of dishes I do every single day
the load of laundry I do every single day
the piling up of clean clothes
cause I absolutely abhor putting up clean clothes
I can wash laundry all day long
but I know everyone agrees with me that putting them up is just
it should be illegal hi honey I need you to stop
okay
so he growls now like an animal you're an animal
hi baby
what you doing
are you waking up
waking up
my 3 major absolutely terrifies me sometimes cause he can be a little mean
no mommy
close the door no
it's me daddy's working
do dishes
who feeds you
okay thank you
you're welcome no
let's go see baby brother
for the life of me I don't know why people are so scared of raw milk
like it logically doesn't even make sense if you eat anything about it
okay no a word
listen to him
oh my god honestly
if my landlords were smart
we would need a pet deposit for both of them
it's the constant cleaning of the playroom and the mat
everyday I clean it
and then 10 minutes later it looks like a bomb went off again
and it's frustrating and you have to remember that you live in a lived in home
it would be different if you're dropping your kids off at school or daycare
or you're out of the house shopping and the house doesn't get touched
I have to explain that sometimes to my husband
you're getting crazy and y'all know what I mean
you have to explain that like listen
an hour ago if you would come home
it was spotless but we lived in it since then
so now it doesn't look spotless
and that's okay because we need to start practicing
moms that maybe don't have a spotless house all the time
but are not burnt out and depressed and overwhelmed
I wish more than anything that I could show my kids